the main goal the campaign is to try to
bring back home farming in the United
States again hi I'm Nicola let's be with
reason TV and today I'm talking with
Eric Steen straw who is the president of
vote hemp a national single issue
nonprofit advocacy group that advocates
for the ability of local producers to
grow and manufacture hemp Eric thanks
for talking with us
tell us what hemp History Week is and
what you're hoping to achieve with it
the main goal the campaign is to educate
consumers about the benefits of
industrial hemp products and try to
bring back home farming in the United
States again right and so people
understand hemp is related it's the
cousin plan of cannabis or a pot but it
has no psychoactive effects on people
currently you can bring it in from
outside the country and use it for
whatever you want but you're just not
allowed to grow it here that's correct
we've got countries all over the world
that are that are producing including
China and Canada and all the European
countries Russia when was it banned in
the United States to grow well so
technically in 1937 when they passed the
marihuana Tax Act it effectively
required producers of cannabis to have a
tax stamp and so that had a major effect
on the production of hemp that made it
much more difficult for farmers to grow
it but it didn't outright outlaw it but
in 1970 the one they passed the
Controlled Substances Act that made it
then all forms of cannabis with without
regard to whether it was industrial
variety or or a drug type cannabis or it
became illegal to grow and I mean in a
lot of ways the ban on hemp on
industrial hemp is the most obvious case
of drug war hysteria right where it's a
it's a plant that is related to
something but it you can't get high off
it it has a lot of uses but we're not
allowed to grow it talk a little bit
about the the forgotten history of
heaven
you know Mountain Vernon's not not very
far from here we actually did a tour in
the first year of hemp history week and
interviewed the folks down there and
they showed us where George Washington
grew it on the farm how he used it for
different products including clothing
and fiber netting for catching fish and
all sorts of things and he wrote about
it in his papers about how important it
was as a crop and they actually had laws
back in the
you know in colonial times requiring
people to grow hemp and they could pay
their taxes with it even so it was a
very important crop historically and it
was grown in the United States up until
the 1930s what would change if we were
allowed to to grow our own hemp well you
know right now we've got dozens of other
countries that are that are allowing
their farmers to grow it and it's
forcing American manufacturers to import
the crop we think that's pretty
ridiculous the markets grown to over
four hundred million dollars a year here
in the US despite the ban and so all
those companies are you know American
farmers are denied the right to be able
to participate in the market they're
denied a good rotation crop that grows
well here and and the biggest part is
you know and this time when we have high
unemployment we need more jobs why would
we do anything like this to limit the
ability to grow more jobs here in the
United States now ad vote hemp you Lobby
against the federal ban on manufacturer
of hemp but then there's also a lot of
state laws how close are you to
affecting change do you think well we
think we've made a lot of progress
seventeen states have passed some form
of legislation or resolution in support
of industrial hemp and there's a lot of
pressure from the states
we've actually got a bill in Congress
right now that's bipartisan with 33
co-sponsors including you know seven
Republicans twenty-five Democrats which
is pretty unusual in this day and age
with all the polarization in Congress
and we've got a senator senator Wyden
from Oregon who's about to introduce a
an amendment to the farm bill and also
some standalone legislation on this as
well well you know there are tons of
hemp products you brought a nice hemp
plus granola
what does hemp add to foods that it's
all over the place right and and that's
that's the great thing about hemp is
it's not you know the the manufacturers
are having it because of the nutritional
benefits it has a perfect balance of
omega-3 and omega-6 essential fatty
acids which doctors are now recommending
for good health what would you say is
the oddest and product that you've
you've encountered yeah you know there's
a lot of great improv out there but I
thought hemp Lube was pretty uh hemp Lou
was pretty interesting yeah all right
that sounds a little bit strange what
how can people find out more about hemp
History Week please go everybody can go
to hemp History Week com and we've got
information on there about all the
locations
where there's gonna be events happening
what stores are carrying the hemp
products thank you Eric I want to thank
Eric Steen straw they had a vote hemp
and the man behind hemp history week for
talking to recent TV today thank you for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie